avec nous ce soir éric la flèche
président et chef de la direction de
métro bonsoir monsieur la flèche
bonsoir monsieur fusion le gouvernement
du québec a annoncé aujourd'hui la
fermeture des commerces des entreprises
sauf les services essentiels vous êtes
un service essentiel ça veut dire quoi
pour vous cette annonce là bas c'est une
mesure sévère mais je pense qu'ils
étaient requises dans les circonstances
nous on se sent une nous sommes un
service essentiel depuis le début de la
crise alors on a un achalandage
important dans nos magasins surtout au
cours des deux dernières semaines
c'est important pour nous de rassurer la
population nous sommes là nous sommes
ouverts n'y a pas de pénurie
d'alimentation au québec 1 signé
ailleurs au canada
alors on est là pour servir nos clients
du mieux qu'on peut êtes vous certain de
manquer de rien en termes
d'approvisionnement
il n'y a pas de danger ou
d'approvisionnement les fabrications là
et leur chaîne de production sont
utilisées au maximum ils peuvent
produire il ya des enjeux de logistique
et de chaîne d'approvisionnement
certains jours de pointe où certains
produits en fonction de leurs
disponibilités des fois c'est des
produits annoncés des fois c'est des
produits trop en demande comme on veut
vous avez connu l'exemple du papier
toilette par exemple que tout le monde
vu amplement alors il ya quelques enjeux
de logistique sur des produits
spécifiques
de façon générale il n'y a pas de
pénurie il n'y a pas d'enjeu
d'approvisionnement est ce qu'il ya un
enjeu de prix est ce qu'il ya des
produits parce qu'on en parlait avec un
autre épicier quelques jours qui disait
que au niveau de l'approvisionnement
lire ab habituels ne sont pas la sks que
des choses en ce moment que les gens
doivent acheter plus cher
il n'y a pas eu de changement de
politique de prix on publie des
circulaires dans toutes nos bannières à
chaque semaine avec les mêmes spéciaux
agressif qu'on fait d'habitude et aucun
enjeu de ce côté là je vous donne parole
on ne se sert pas de cette crise là pour
augmenter quelque prix que ce soit
cela dit il peut y avoir des enjeux
d'approvisionnement dues à des
commodités des prix de marché qui
peuvent fluctuer
la devise canadienne fluctue
rapport à la devise américaine en ce
moment ça ça peut avoir des impacts sur
certaines coûtant et nous on s'engage à
ne pas augmenter nos marges de quelque
façon que ce soit et de garder les prix
les plus compétitifs possible surtout
dans une crise comme ça comme d'autres
commerces vous avez augmenté le salaire
de vos employés
exactement je peux pas vous dire à quel
point on a des employés fantastique dans
l'équipe métro et dans tous les
supermarchés en général ces gens là
travaillent jour et nuit littéralement
font des heures supplémentaires bien
au-delà des attentes normal pour servir
les clients et je pense qu'il était
important d'assurer leur sécurité
autant physique que financière ces gens
là font d'énormes sacrifices alors comme
quelques autres de nos concurrents nous
avons décidé d'augmenter le salaire
horaire de 2 dollars jeter a été très
bien reçu par nos équipes et plexiglas
dont le voyait aussi que vous êtes là
c'est une autre mesure qu'on a commencé
à installer dans nos magasins à partir
d'aujourd'hui les démarches étaient en
cours depuis la semaine dernière trouver
le fournisseur les spécifications les
équipes d'installation tout était en
marche depuis quelques jours et on a
commencé à installer aujourd'hui même au
québec et en ontario il ya dix équipes
par province qui installe jour et nuit d
plexiglas à toutes les pièces de nos
magasins pour respecter la distance
entre la caissière et le client des
épiceries réserve une plage horaire pour
les 70 ans et plus le docteur arruda
disait ce matin qu'il est préférable que
les aînés ne sortent pas est ce que vous
prenez des dispositions particulières
pour servir cette clientèle précisément
en raison des directives la santé
publique on a choisi de ne pas réserver
de plages horaires pour les personnes de
70 ans et plus dans nos magasins au
québec parce que le gouvernement du
québec a émis cette directive et on veut
s'y conformer on évite la population les
familles les amis à faire le magasinage
pour ces personnes-là si elle d'où son
seul et doit venir à nos magasins on va
les accueillir c'est bien évident en
ontario il n'y a pas de telles
directives et on a réservé une plage
horaire de 7 à 8 pour les 70 ans et plus
dans plusieurs de nos magasins potosi
mais dans plusieurs des magasins où ces
permis
vous avez dit hausse du chiffre
d'affaires est ce que vous avez prévu
redistribuer une partie des profits
supplémentaires que vous faites en ce
moment il y à des clientèles en
difficulté je pense aux ménages les plus
démunis
les banques alimentaires notamment
définitivement écouter on supporte nos
employés comme on le dit avant tout et
on va faire de grands efforts pour les
plus démunis métro supporte depuis très
longtemps centraide les banques
alimentaires je copréside moi même la
campagne majeure des banques
alimentaires du québec en ce moment avec
l'immigration et catherine dagenais
c'est certain qu'on va faire un geste
additionnel on est très ressemblant quoi
monsieur la flèche bas on va augmenter
ou non on a déjà que mille cinq cent
mille dollars aux banques alimentaires
du québec on va augmenter ce don là de
façon substantielle je peux vous donner
le chiffre je veux parler amicaux
président avant de vous annoncer ça mais
on va faire quelque chose de plus c'est
certain et aussi pour centraide d'un
fonds d'urgence pour centraide qui étend
qui est en fait d'être mis sur pied sa
métro est un partenaire de longue date
de centraide et on va être là transat a
dit aujourd'hui que ses dirigeants
air transat la ses dirigeants à adopter
une réduction volontaire de leur
rémunération de même que le conseil
d'administration est ce qu est ce que
c'est votre cas également
non ce n'est pas le cas chez métro métro
est en excellente santé financière on
est par chance une industrie qui est
plus stable dans l'est dans
l'environnement actuel
alors c'était pas une mesure qui était
nécessaire de prendre chez métro les
commandes en ligne sont en forte hausse
vous faciliter les commandes en ligne
on a un service de commande en ligne qui
est qui est en marche depuis quelques
années et la demande en ce moment est
est très très forte alors le
la capacité de notre service en ligne
est malheureusement limitée alors on est
on avait mis des ressources à suffire à
la demande ça prend quelques jours pour
avoir sa commande
alors on encourage les gens qui sont en
bonne santé capable de faire de se
rendre au magasin et de laisser plus de
place plus de plage sur le commerce en
ligne pour les gens qui sont en
situation plus difficile comme les
personnes aidées dont vous avez parlé
tout à l'heure
alors oui le commandant en ligne
fonctionne mais mais la demande est
forte comme dans nos magasins d'ailleurs
merci monsieur la flèche
ça m'a fait plaisir merci